boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on we
are on site at the raw Science Film
Festival the fifth annual one where we
are spreading amazing scientific ideas
through film and media we are really
excited to be talking to the producers
correct of behind the group of creators
creators of behind the groove awesome
we have Sydney we have Jesse we have
Sheldon joining us thank you so much for
coming onto the show and chadon
appreciate it a lot of you thanks guys
thank you
behind the groove is very exciting it's
and then all I'll ask you guys to share
but for me when you guys were sharing
the idea I was thinking about all the
unsung heroes period just all the people
that are not highlighted that need to be
highlighted the ones that worked with
the people that are good this worked
with the stars and this is the song as a
hit song basically behind the groove is
the unsung heroes behind your favorite
hit songs they had to have had a hit
song to be on our program basically and
in any capacity they had to work on the
song whether they were a singer whether
they writer whether they were a composer
whether they were a magician whether
they were just in the room while I was
being made engineering what you know
whatever it is a coach they just were a
part of the song and so this is
specifically music and so this is
interesting because one of the first
things that came to my mind was about
this tech companies because within the
tech companies you see musk in the media
but you never see the next level at
SpaceX and Tesla who's actually
contributing to the building out all of
what they're doing and so but you're
highlighting and there's the same thing
with film as well I'm just saying with
film as well you see the cast but you
never see for example here are all
science film festival we're not
highlighting the technical directors and
the audio engineers and said yeah so
tell us about how you found these you
know well first of all tell us about how
you found the idea of behind the groove
to be super important there's no one's
doing this quite yet and it's exciting
well thank you okay well one of the
concepts was we were just wanted to
bridge the gap between the Bay
boomers in the Millennials we wanted to
teach people about where the real music
came from and who were the real artists
behind the music and that's basically
behind the groove and Jessie right here
is man we've all been working together
for a year a little over a year now for
this project but they had it as a behind
the groove but then they brought me on
and I had a thing called conscious but
the fruit gallery so we combined it
together and it really made sense and
it's really what we want to do and we
want to educate the people we want to
let people know how to do different
things in the music industry that's why
we have business associates we have
people who do music and you know all
aspects we want to cover that and we
want to teach people about music the
real music about everything encompass
and one thing about behind the groove is
okay I work with Sheldon and Sheldon's
business manager and so trying to do
some things a little bit different we
know where his career and so I'm Sheldon
as you know always wanted to do some
things with television and so on him and
I we do a lot of brainstorming and so on
there was a segment that we were going
to do on another project that I had that
I wanted to bring Sheldon on board you
know with that and it was you know
behind the groove and you know talking
about individuals that are you know
behind hit songs and so you know for me
I used to read it album covers and did
that for years and and I would I would
go in downtown Detroit just going to
record shop and just read album covers
so then as I got got I got older I
started paying attention to these
different music shows and so they were
all about creating stars but I'm
thinking well what about the other
people what about those that contributed
toward making that song what it is
then as I begin your work with Sheldon I
said we need to we need to focus on that
and we need to know give them their just
due and you know I looked at on beyond
the Funk Brothers and I saw all the
great work that they were doing and were
unrecognized and I saw the pain and one
of the guitar player that had played the
lick on I think it was on my girl and he
was sitting in a restaurant and he's
playing as he's hearing this lick
playing he said that's me that's then
all of a sudden he kind of pulled back
because he it was oh yeah that's me but
I'm kind of hurt so you know looking at
that you know looking at the documentary
said you know we need to know recognize
these individuals they they've done
great work great contribution to music
so people need to know who they are and
so behind the group is gonna do that for
them it's gonna educate the younger
generation on real music and and let
them know it's work you need skills you
know it's it's more than creating music
just pushing a couple buttons but
there's there's a team of people that's
involved that makes that song what it is
and that's what behind the groove was
all about I'm basically diddle what they
both have said but I see it as this is a
wonderful opportunity opportunity for us
to bring homage and honor to people who
are often forgotten that's that's the
main reason we're doing this it seems to
me that there's actually two very
fascinating parts to this there's both
honoring the people that are so often
forgotten I love the story of going in
reading album covers because then you
actually go and see all of the people
involved yeah yeah involved in it in one
song even know one song one song and
then and then so it's part of the the
unsung heroes and the other part is then
it there's an educational component
- this of there's actually a dozen roles
for people to train in - so it's not
just about this wanting to become the
star but there's like 12 other rules
that come with the star that need to be
and at these tech companies there's a
thousand roles that need to be filled
yes so this is what's very interesting
so tell us about the like the
educational piece as well right now
we're working on a educational piece for
three colleges we're gonna write that
curricular based on behind the groove
and what we feel would help educate the
youth on what the new music should be
and how they can carry it across and
bring it across to others one would tell
us about what that curriculum is in a
little more depth well like what it
should be like you said real music
playing real instruments teaching them
how to play the real instruments and
notes learning how to read sheet music
which is real like a real musician they
know how to read music
most kids nowadays they know how to play
by ear they don't know how to read the
sheet music they'd be like yeah I can
play that but okay can you read the
music tell me what that note is I bet
you they can't most of them can nowadays
they don't even have that curricular in
school anymore that's out so we want to
bring that back and have a way for
schools to generate funds for the kids
to be in those classes so that's one of
the things that we're doing also good
mainly just giving the education about
how how to do it as a business how to do
it as a professional as a singer how to
do it in every realm where you be taught
that you taught the ways of all the all
the practices that are done
business-wise how you can get paid you
know all that pretty much that's the
number one thing that everybody wants to
do after they make the hit song is get
paid but yeah that's pretty much we want
to do help people
our main thing is helping youth
and to be able to encourage the younger
generation to pick up an instrument and
because creativity comes through the
through the instrument itself and so to
understand that first of all you need to
learn how to play an instrument then as
you begin to learn how to play an
instrument then you be begin to become
creative and so we want to encourage
youth to pick up an instrument learn how
to play the instrument and then develop
a deeper understanding through learning
how to play the instrument than you then
now all of a sudden you have a deeper
respect for music and you know that
there's effort put forth to develop that
skill it might take you 10 15 years but
you will be very good at it you have a
deeper understanding because now you
have to create it it's from your
imagination it's not from pushing a
button this is coming straight from you
it's coming straight from your heart so
to encourage the generation to okay pick
up an instrument and like for example
like somebody like Sheldon though they
were asking about earth wind fire tune
called gratitude so the guy asked
Shelley said yeah where did they sample
that from and she said god that's not
sample they actually planned then so
that says something that it takes skill
to do that it's not automatic
I mean you have to train the fingers
like train the mind
it comes from the heart
spirit soul now all of a sudden that you
can touch people that that music it gets
to the emotions of people so you want to
go you want to get that deep with it so
that way now all of a sudden your music
is touching people one of the things
that I would repeat is the importance of
learning how to read music there's a lot
of there's a lot of natural talent in
turning in terms of playing and picking
up on stuff that you hear and that's a
great thing to have but you may walk
into a studio one day and a producer
says I've got a China I want you to read
this is how I want the music to go and
he may not be open for any your
embellishment so you got to know how to
read it and then it's a very important
piece okay this is so cool to me as well
because we're kind of we're at this
tipping point at an inflection of we
have about seven point seven billion
people we have exponential technology
and entering into every single industry
artificial intelligence is now in music
as well and yeah so this is probably
more important than ever for us to be
picking up and working with the as like
a synthesis between an artificial
intelligence and our own creativity and
that requires being able to read sheet
music that requires being able to pick
up an instrument this also speaks really
heavily to me about the create don't
just consume mantra so when you show
people that there's dozens of
opportunities within like hits on songs
and albums etc that then they then
realize that oh I can also fill one of
those roles so I like I like that this
this aspect to it a lot because about
this the wave of the future is the youth
and if they're not out there creating
music what are they doing where's the
new music consuming you but if it's a I
write that doesn't have soul or heart oh
that's interesting yeah so you're not
gonna get that real vibe that you're
supposed to be feeling because that
feeling is where it's at the emotion but
if you can't tell the difference okay
you know on a performance you're right
you're right because you can pocket you
know let it teach us about in pocket
okay in pocket well it's a synergy built
up between all the artists performing
together and they're gonna hit that
pocket where that sound is perfect in
pocket there's a thing we used to do
with ewf where we may start a song off
at a certain tempo and if the audience
doesn't respond the way we were still we
were accustomed to it Maurice might turn
around and saying pick it up I'll slow
it down but you can't lose the feeling
of the music either way you go and we
used to always wonder then he'd say put
it on the backbeat which men don't rush
it but put it right on the edge of being
behind a little bit and all those kind
of terminologies you got to know him and
you got to got to recognize them on the
spot but otherwise you'll turn around
look at you and go one thing that I do
is study I study pretty music and from
the vocals to the instrumentation and
I'll say what makes that song pretty
what makes me play that song like 10
times in a row what makes me go back and
listen to that song over and over and
over there's something about that
that that touches the heart that touches
the emotion okay that comes from you
that comes from the creator of that
music gets that deep and when you see
people like for example Kay Sheldon
performs with the earth wind fire group
called kalimba okay I share with people
if you close your eyes you couldn't tell
the difference I mean they're that good
and by shelter performing with them that
same energy is there the people they
they feel it they hear the original
songs they feel the energy and they're
they're just as lively as if they've
actually gone to earth wind fire concert
because the music does it that music is
so great my cousin went to the concert
in New York she could stop NASA they
would just come to hits after hit that
people getting more excited more excited
more excited because those are great
memories those songs are timeless people
go back in their life and remember great
times so there's a lot of power it music
a lot of power in that was yet there's a
there's a feeling that overtakes those
of the heart when you're it's just that
spirit being communicated from the
artists to the audience and you're
you're in the pocket was really
interesting
the different like you know you give you
bring it you got to read the audience
and dynamically adjust was
instantaneously that was very
interesting and that's for like a live
audience but for its it's also
interesting to think about for a for
someone that's just listening via their
headphones at home or on the go wherever
they're going not at a live performance
there may be a spirit that comes from
the compute comes from the computer as
well but is this is very strange that
we're at this time but
we're right there and it's I want to ask
you guys a quick question okay you've
done nine episodes is that right no
actually we're we've done what three
three to two you've done two episodes
featuring nine artists two episodes with
nine artists and then and then how are
you identifying the artists and then how
do you identify the people that actually
have a list of artists that are going to
perform with us and that's in our
package that have agreed already to do
the shows with us because these artists
are the same unsung heroes they there's
so many people that we are in contact
with that work with Sheldon's work with
Jesse's work with I've worked with and
the people on our team have worked
together and so people come to us and
say hey I want to be part of that once
they hear what we're doing everybody
wants to jump on board and say hey look
I like that because not too many people
like the new music I'm just being real
they don't like well there's got to be a
more meaning in the music right yeah
because trap music and you only got
they're only saying like three words
panda panda panda panda that's one word
that was a hit song I don't know how how
did that happen we've changed this you
know how we've dumbed down ourselves to
listen to I don't know panda pandas not
gonna last you want to also identify the
heroes that are making meaningful music
that are not being recognized and
identified so you know even even the new
artists if they're actually doing
something like Bruno Mars yeah I think
he's probably got the right mode going
his Bruno Mars I can only use him as
Justin Timberlake he's another artist
not even Justin Bieber but Justin
Timberlake you know he's a good Shawn
Mendes he's nearly he's really doing
something you know I like him Khalil I
don't know if you know Kali I mean
Khalid and
they got a good track because I do radio
DJ too also so hearing the new hit songs
is pretty up-to-date but most people
Bruno Mars so I'm gonna go with him
where can we find behind the groove
right now behind the groove Las Vegas
calm okay behind the groove Las Vegas
calm that link is in the bio I want to
ask you guys one quick question on the
way out which is which is what do you
think's the most beautiful thing in the
world
[Music]
think like having a loving and humble
spirit to pour into into the lives of
others and taking what like taking your
your experiences and sharing those
experiences with others so this way it
makes the road easier for them and so I
know you know for myself I'm always
looking to give back to people always
looking to help people and I'm satisfied
with just being able to do something to
make a difference in their life to make
that road a little bit easier so they
can get to the point of success a lot
quicker
check me out love is the convergence
between the waves of sound and the ways
of all light coming together and making
us create songs peace peace and we'll
you know we'll we'll wrap on that I
really want to you know thank you guys
for putting this forward putting behind
the group forward also to also the idea
is so important for other people to
potentially take and start doing it in
film showing behind the groove in tech
showing behind the groove in all these
other yeah it says this is really good
I'm happy you're pushing a yeah you're
doing the right thing thank you three so
much for coming on the show thanks
everyone for tuning a greatly appreciate
check out the link in the bio below give
us your thoughts in the comments as well
and keep supporting awesome artists and
entrepreneurs that you believe in much
love and we'll see you soon
peace